let's start with natty i got a few notes
over here let's start with natural
so
actually let's take a few steps back why
is testosterone important well it's
probably the most important male hormone
that you want to optimize
and if you haven't got it optimized
you're going to know
you're going to be fat sick unhealthy
probably infertile you're going to have
ed issues
part of probably cardiovascular health
issues
so
i mean it's no joke guys um
you're gonna want to take this seriously
because
most people don't if i'm being honest
and it's really really easy to stand out
from the crowd like
most people are sleepwalking through
life they're they're they've surrounded
themselves by turkeys and it's real real
easy to soar like an eagle in today's
world if you if you just do some basic
things okay
a lot of them i've talked about in prior
podcasts on this series
and
i'll be honest with you
uh you know the information develops and
changes over time but
guys again if you get it wrong it's it's
it's a serious problem so uh huberman
defined what testosterone means as a
hormone to men i think the best
and he said that it makes effort feel
good
okay
a lot of people point and sputter in
today's world they blame everybody else
for their results there's an entitled
mentality
um you know accept me for who i am blah
blah blah all that stuff that's a whole
bunch of [ __ ]
one of the problems that we're dealing
with today is testosterone levels in men
is at the lowest point it's ever been
throughout history um but i'm well
you can't say that for certain
throughout history because we don't have
blood labs from a thousand years ago
but
we know as far back as they've been
tracking it that testosterone levels
have dropped dramatically um there was
mention actually i think in dr anthony
j's book it's called estrogeneration
that
they were able to determine that because
of the bone structure and the jawline of
um skeletons male skeletons especially
from certain regions in the world
they were able to determine that
testosterone levels were in fact higher
um back in those days as well too
because the higher your t levels two
things end up happening i think that
it's the um third finger that ends up
growing longer than your index it's one
and two your jaw line becomes more
pronounced it gets more squared off
so um
yeah
the evidence is there anyway
so here's how you optimize it um
a lot of people are gonna go on you're
gonna see in the comments already i bet
it's already going to trt
um
somewhere somebody's yeah uh nc's in the
uh chat he's actually a natural
bodybuilder uh that's that's what you
can look like at 40 um if you
live the right life you know if i'm
being honest with you you can
you can do a lot with testosterone
um it's
it's something that you want to get
familiar with i'm not even joking right
like most guys get this wrong
most guys in their youth when they're
natural get it young most guys even if
they go on therapeutic dosages of
testosterone dr prescribed and
supervised
also tend to get it pretty wrong so
again this is an important one
um so as far as
as a natural i'm going to tell you this
straight up comparing
your body's own endogenous production
that your testes make
versus what you can inject in your body
or apply as a cream or get as a pellet
or a sublingual a thing you put under
your tongue
exogenous so we have endogenous meaning
you're it's produced by your nut sac
versus something that you inject in your
body or take a pill or you introduce
your body's exogenous
natural testosterone is far superior
hands down there's no [ __ ] question
about it
um
i can tell you for a fact that i was
stronger when i was 25 than what i am
right now
and my testosterone levels i have no
idea what they were at 25 because i was
too stupid to take labs at that time
but i know i was way stronger and i
probably arguably had a better build
because when you take therapeutic
testosterone you're going to end up
with a little bit of water retention
and you're going to have a conversion to
estrogen
if you don't manage it properly which
again is is part of the water retention
part or part of that component as well
so hands down before you go rushing out
they're going i gotta go find a doctor
and get trt straight up guys you can be
natural
pretty much for your entire life you
know if you if you really want to if you
if your body can produce it and you're
happy with the levels and you feel like
you're operating in an optimized way
um
petey mangan i did a podcast on my plane
to win series i think he's 67
he's on twitter his lingo is sun steak
steel
actually let me see i know some of you
guys probably know let me see if i can
find the picture that was posted the
other day
because
um it's something that deserves a hat
tip
yeah here it is let me throw it up on
the screen
share screen this guy's a dude all right
he is 67.
so in this picture it says uh bill gates
is 66 years old and this is this is the
guy telling you to eat bugs and and you
know vegan meat dude looks like he's
like seven months pregnant
petey mangan is 67 so a year older and
he and he preaches sun steel steak this
is this dude over here
i've had him on an interview on on the
playing the win um it's worth checking
out if that's something you're
interested in but pd's
natural right
he's not big i can't remember what his
height and weight was but it's not it's
not impressive and when i had him on the
interview he doesn't look like he's
jacked in that picture but he's fit and
he's healthy
and you can tell he's
very happy with the way that he lives
his life so my advice is is don't rush
out and try to get therapeutic you know
testosterone try to optimize yourself
your
the the production that you're going to
get from your nut sac is going to be far
superior than what any pharmaceutical
company is ever going to put in a vial
doesn't matter how the engineer it
doesn't [ __ ] matter it it was not
made in your own body so your own
production is by far the best thing that
to to optimize in my view
some people might argue that
i'm going to talk about you know
exogenous tea as well because i'm on it
and i've been on it for
five years now so i have a lot of
experience there too
but um
optimize what your nut sac makes first
and foremost try to be as natural as
long as you can and don't like don't
[ __ ] around like don't be a lazy fat
bastard that sits around smoking weed
eating food all day long and like doing
nothing with yourself and you end up
fattening out of shape with like man
boobs um deal with this from a younger
age the sooner that you can get this in
check the easier it's going to be for
you to live a longer healthier life
optimized
in such a way where
you just feel good right i mean
i got a little bit of a tan going on
today like i spend my time the way that
i want to spend it i make money
most of the time i'm not even working
and it gives me the opportunity to hop
on my bike and be like [ __ ] it i'm gonna
go get a nice coffee and go for a nice
bike ride and get some sunshine some
free vitamin d and you know that's how i
like to use my time
you're going to have freedom for it but
younger is when you want to optimize
this hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you